[Musique]
yes
s
[Musique]
bush
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
thanks for rating
or mon sens la suite d'affaires en
france est plutôt merci à tous d'avoir
regardé cette vidéo ça fait des années
que je suis hyper fan des morceaux ou
puis à base de bruitages à son stop
jacques godet mancuso ou encore julian
smith je voulais absolument faire un
petit clip de ce style à ma façon sur
une thématique qui me passionne en ce
moment c'est à dire la paternité la
maternité aussi si vous avez qui fait
n'hésitez pas à mettre un petit pouce en
l'air l'année recommence il va y avoir
plein de petits contenu sur la chaîne
youtube
donc restez connectés normalement on se
revoit très très bientôt
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
on
le
[Musique]
et